this weekend our ion money series we
focus on the costly mistakes people make
with their finances student loan debt is
a huge problem for many graduates and
their families college students graduate
with an average debt of more than
$28,000 nationwide student debt topped
one and a half trillion dollars at the
end of 2018 we spoke to Megan Combs who
went to college to pursue an art career
at age 32 she is still struggling to pay
for her education I just want to get
this paid I just want to be in the clear
I'm so tired of this debt Meghan Combs
is burdened by the student loans she
took out to pursue her dream of working
in the arts I was 5 years old and I was
drawing stick figures and I think the
enthusiasm from my parents about my six
figures made me want to be an artist
after receiving her undergraduate degree
she owed just under ten thousand dollars
in student loans combs was told in order
to achieve her goal of being a museum
curator she needed a master's degree I
was accepted in New York City and so I
thought oh this is gonna be great this
is gonna be so easy to get a museum job
in New York City so my dad actually
encouraged me to live off of my loans
and to not work during grad school cuz
he said you need to devote 110 percent
of your time and energy to this combs
took out 61 thousand dollars in loans
and has made nearly twenty seven
thousand dollars in payments but because
those payments were too small to cover
the interest she now owes sixty six
thousand dollars more than her original
loans I it will shoulder some of the
blame there because I should have read
the fine print on every single one of my
loans after pursuing a career in the art
world for five years without finding
full-time work combs made a career
change she now works at a tech startup
but is still struggling to pay off her
student loan debt I'm able to pay about
$900 a month on it you know that is
really stretching me as thin as I can
possibly go CBS News business analyst
Jill Schlesinger writes about the impact
of college debt and her new
rape book the dumb thing smart people do
with their money 13 ways to write your
financial wrongs she was also a
certified financial planner and Jill you
or somebody Meaghan should have called
many people can relate to her obviously
she owes sixty six thousand dollars on
her loan what should she have done
differently again if we could turn back
time she would have actually thought
what is it that I can do with this
graduate degree because as you said she
graduated undergrad with less than ten
thousand dollars so you really want to
be realistic what will this do for me
and now we've got so much information
about what careers will pay so do a
little research will this degree
actually allow me to get a job that pays
enough and you know when I look at that
being realistic it really has to be a
family thing I love that her father's
sort of encouraging but at some point
you want as a family to say hey wait a
second we got to take a timeout here and
see what's gonna happen you want to also
read the fine print of those loans
because don't forget she did say that
she didn't realize she was getting into
a payment program which would kind of
freeze the loan and actually have an
increase over time and I would say the
biggest piece for her is she's gonna try
to right now accelerate the pay down of
this debt $900 a month great every
available dollar maybe she puts into the
match for her retirement account but use
all money to pay that loan down as
quickly as think she's on a right path
now paying 900 a month I think if she
can do more great and for parents and
students who are now gonna be getting
their acceptance letters into college
over the next few weeks what are some of
the negotiating tips because I was
surprised in your book you say you can
negotiate college tuition this is a
fascinating fact that is not actually
very widely disseminated and that is
that when you get your package from
various schools you can kind of play one
against the other now you have to do so
as the student him or herself mommy and
daddy you can't call so what you want to
do is you want to say to the college hey
ABC University has given me a package
worth this much could you match it can
you actually help me out what kind of
work-study is there going to be again
you've got to figure out whether this
degree is going to translate
into an a career and you can pay that
debt down and actually achieve your
future financial goals and we know
millions of Americans will have to
resort to taking out a student loan
there's nothing wrong with that but what
are some of the things they should look
out for so the big trap that people fall
into is just taking on gobs of debt like
Megan did assuming the best-case
scenario now I want you to assume the
worst case scenario and say to yourself
hey I'm going to be having a job it's
not gonna make that much money so think
of it this way the first job you get out
of college let's say you make $30,000
that's the total amount of borrowing
that should be done and for parents I
don't care whether your kid wants to be
the most sophisticated artist artistic
collector in the world or academic do
not delay any retirement plans on your
part to put those kids through school
you as a family have to be realistic you
have to all be able to afford for these
decisions college degrees pay off but
they don't do so if you have the
overhang of thousands and thousands of
dollars of debt either for the parents
the grandparents or the kids think about
the long-term ripple effects indeed feel
great to have you on thanks so much
everybody to go buy your book and if you
have questions about student loan debt
head to the CBS this morning Facebook
page now and Jill we'll continue the
conversation and answer your questions
there